welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this video were
breaking down the new Vin Diesel vehicle
that isn't the fast and furious get it
cuz cuz diesel vehicle nevermind
throughout this video we're gonna be
going over the stars new film bloodshot
it's ending and where things could be
heading for the future there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check the film out yet
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns like this every
day
and please hit the like button if you
enjoy the recap without the way thank
you for clicking the video now let's get
into our breakdown of blood shot the
most important assets in the US military
soldiers like yourself you're the first
who we successfully managed to bring
back but improved enhanced with the
technology in your veins you have an
army inside you
we make you stronger they will heal you
instantly
okay so bloodshot is based on the
valiant comic book series of the same
name and it follows the basic structure
of that for the film bloodshot has been
in development hell for almost a decade
now with the movie being pushed into
production all the way back in 2012
Jared Leto was set to star in it but as
we know that didn't work out and it took
almost six years for it to get off the
ground before finally beginning
production in 2018 it centers around ray
garrison played by Vin Diesel a marine
that has seen his fair share of combat
over the years this has taken its toll
on him and his body though he doesn't
seem like he wishes to give up the life
anytime soon ray is addicted to combat
orders and going where people point him
to and this very much place into the
plot and how it develops after returning
from a mission in Mombasa ray and his
wife are kidnapped by a man named Martin
axe he was apparently connected to the
aforementioned job axe becomes an
interchangeable term but for the
meantime I'll just be using this as his
name axe kills Ray's wife in front of
him before shooting him in the head
ray isn't dead though and he comes back
with a vengeance
it's a Robocop tale of the 21st century
and Ray is resurrected by scientists
using the latest cutting-edge
nanotechnology to revive him these
nanites are injected into his blood
hence the name bloodshot after pretty
much having his memory completely white
he's on a mission to discover who he
really is
bloodshot is guided by dr. Emil hotting
a scientist that works for rst as you
may have expected the character played
by Guy Pearce is the main villain and no
I did predict this off the trailers I
did appreciate at least how the reveal
was handled the company have carried out
experiments on a number of people
including Katy Tibbs and Dalton who all
now have prosthetic implants to enhance
their abilities and basically the group
of guns for hire I'll talk about this
more in depth in a bit but similar to
his military life ray is just going
wherever they tell him to Ray is now
owned by rst and must carry out jobs on
behalf of them but they want this to be
without question hence the procedure
he's pretty much their puppet
and over the mission he begins to learn
the truth about his past as he uncovers
what's really going on imagine imagine
the Winter Soldier / everyone looks like
Red Skull that's that's the basic plot
of the movie
bloodshot is almost invincible due to
the new tech that flows through his
veins and with nanobots he's able to
shift his mass integrate with electrical
systems and heal almost instantly from
injury he's able to push himself harder
and faster than any man before an
apparently blood shot is the first to
survive a full transfusion that's the
basic groundwork of the plot and this
journey sort of questions whether the
life of a soldier belongs to themselves
or the army that has enlisted them
soldiers are often expected to follow
orders blindly and bloodshot to me is
about ensuing this through manipulation
going into blood Shaw I didn't expect it
to be varied by the numbers and whilst
it initially appears that way on the
surface for the first 40 minutes it
changes things up and allows the film to
have an interesting aesthetic to it this
is an origin story in its truest sense
and because of that it has to follow
certain confines in setting up the
character discovering their abilities
but it does alter things in certain ways
you can pretty much tell what's going to
happen in the film if you watch any of
the trailers and it hits all of the
beats that you'd expect the cast itself
are really good with what they have
though and Vin Diesel plays the tortured
action hero that is tormented by his
amnesia while so don't think that diesel
has much range the actor always finds
parts that compliment him in my opinion
he pulls off roles like this really well
and whether it's Riddick Fast and the
Furious or bloodshot he fits the part
well for me right tracks down acts who
seems like a shell of the man that Ray
met before
and when enacting his revenge acts
utters the words you're making a mistake
the fight severely depleted of his
nanites which plays into the ending of
the movie when he returns to base they
say that they will recharge him and
explain everything this is a ruse and
they can find him wipe his memory and
admit that his wife is still alive we
learned that rst have completely
manufactured his backstory and the
majority of what we've seen so far ray
was actually dead before the movie
started and this is all being a
simulation built to provide him with a
backstory to do their bidding
rst have complete control over
brain and can alter how he remembers the
death of his wife they are able to
configure acts so that he wears the face
of his next target
every target he goes after is an axe
with him and I got flashes of guy
Pearce's of the work memento which had a
similar sort of mindless killer motif
his awakening training and revival are
all scripted by rst who drive him to
hunt and the only one who seems to be
twisted by this is Kati upon going to
attack another target named Baris who is
replaced axe things change up massively
and this sets us on a course for the end
of the film after an EMP is used to
disable as nanomachines he's captured by
a man named Wiggins and the to uncover
the truth ray manages to find his wife
however he learns that they've been
divorced for a long time and that she
moved on life in the army severely
affected their relationship and raised
refusal to leave the fight cost them
their marriage ray has been working for
rst for five years and it's a gut punch
for the character that really caught me
off guard
as mentioned earlier bloodshot does a
great job of changing things up from
what you'd expect and this sets the
stakes for the finale
rst track him down and after an action
in chase scene they manage to capture
him caite is sent out to bring Wiggins
in and due to her ability to inhale
toxins she knocks him out with a
cigarette laced with sleeping gas the
good doc takes right into a simulation
and he explains the situation as
mentioned earlier this touches upon the
prior points of soldier vs. the army and
how commanding officers often view the
people fighting their Wars as statistics
they become emotionally detached in
sending them to their death and this
perception has enabled hearting to do
the wipes - ray countless times
regardless of his feelings or the life
that he won't have harding argues that
orders provide purpose handle reality
and it's an interesting character study
for a man who devoted his life to war
over his family I think that the movie
could have easily avoided this topic and
just went with a brainless action flick
so I did enjoy them at least doing
something that the audience could debate
over KT returns but she has a change of
heart
RS t begin to wipe Ray's memory again /
KT enters the simulation to free em
before the process can be carried out
using Wiggins they manage to break the
spell and KT goes rogue forcing tips and
Dalton to don Excel
skeletons whilst they try and kill
bloodshot it's an awesome finale
even if Dalton does look like a discount
Doc Ock that sees the two working on a
falling elevator to try and kill him he
goes full bloodshot mode with the
nanites activating turning his eyes red
and skin completely white
unfortunately this massively depletes
him and though he manages to kill Dalton
and Tibbs he's in full overlock mode
after finally catching up to hearten the
villain shoots a grenade that completely
decimates bloodshot who has to push
himself to the brink in order to
recharge this completely drops his
nanites and left with non he goes to
Harting hardin grabs him around the neck
and using one of the undetonated
grenades at Harding fire at him he blows
the two up now where the Harting is dead
is a bit up in the air at the moment we
never see the character die on screen
and there are actually a lot of fan
theories floating around that say he
could have injected himself with nanites
and thus survived this encounter
he's there if they need him to come back
though I do kind of doubt it for the
final few scenes right wakes up and he
remembers everything Wiggins has
upgraded the character and with Katy the
to head off into the sunset together
they've decided that their past doesn't
define them and that they can choose who
they want to be going ahead now before
we get into the rest of the video I just
want to let you know we're giving away a
free copy of the infinity Saga box set
to one random subscriber all you have to
do to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the updates
in the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
March in the cell be shipped out from
then to ever gets the prize it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
okay so going ahead though a sequel for
bloodshot is yet to be confirmed the
film only cost 42 million dollars which
is a relatively modest budget especially
in terms of comic book movies the film
was always intended to kick-start the
Valiant Comics universe and though it's
pretty far behind the MCU now as the
project was meant to begin in 2012 there
will definitely be ideas in place I
think originally the series was meant to
start with two films based upon the
Harbinger comic which would then
culminate in a crossover called
Harbinger Wars
however due to infinity war releasing
and a number of other notable
comparisons and films that didn't quite
hit the mark
studio we thought this instead Sony
announced that they would be releasing
bloodshot first which would kick things
off the rights of the series are also a
bit up in the air at the moment as
paramount actually announced in 2012
that Harbinger was going to be
distributed by Paramount which could
start there being a shared universe
however I think what will happen is that
they will likely continue with it but
Sony and Paramount will share custody of
the characters similar to Marvel and
Universal did with the Hulk and
spider-man Paramount actually
kick-started the MCU before Disney
bought Marvel and no people forget they
were the ones that distributed Iron Man
1 and to Thor and Captain America so it
is possible that they could all work
together and paramount likely want to
create a foundation for another Shetty
universe going forward I can actually
see them skipping a number of volumes
and for a second film a thing on the
best story to adapt would be the fourth
release in this bloodshot has his
nanites removed and he tries to live a
normal life but he's pulled back into
the fray when a number of shootings are
carried out by people that look like him
whether they do that or not you know I
don't really know but there is a lot to
play with and out of everything and that
is why I would imagine as for the film
itself I did have fun watching it though
as I mentioned things on the whole went
the way that you would expect birdshot
isn't trying to reinvent the wheel but
adds a lot of fun to be had with it
especially if you went into the movie
knowing very little bloodshot was a
blast
and those shared universes are a dime a
dozen right now this one actually
interests me I hope the film does well
enough to garner a sequel as I would
love to see what can come from this but
if not it's still a fun enough
self-contained story
bloodshot was a good ride and it gets a
7 out of 10 now obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on bloodshot and what
you want to see next time if we get
another film comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our ending explained on
the outsider which is gonna be linked at
the end we go over everything you need
to know about the big HBO show so please
check it out after this you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below you massively appreciate it
as a thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at Definition
YT or click the
is called link in the description below
those are the best ways to keep
up-to-date with the channel so hopefully
we see over there very soon this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you